Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vous en avez peut être entendu parler
il y a quelques semaines,
l'acteur et comédien Fabrice Luchini
annonçait avoir vendu sa maison
sur l'île de Ré.
Il est persuadé qu'elle sera noyée
sous les eaux d'ici une dizaine d'années.
Alors, a-t-il fait le bon choix ?
Une chose est sûre,
depuis un peu plus d'un siècle,
le niveau des océans ne cesse de grimper.
Et ce n'est pas près de s'arrêter,
avec le réchauffement climatique
et la fonte des glaces.
La France métropolitaine,
avec 5500 kilomètres de côtes,
est directement menacée.
Alors, comment en est on arrivé là
et jusqu'où ça va monter ?
C'est l'objet de cette vidéo.
En ce moment, vous en entendez parler tous les jours,
se tient à Dubaï la COP 28.
La COP
ou Conférence des parties, conference of the parties,
pour respecter l'acronyme, est un sommet
annuel durant lequel 197 États
se réunissent pour discuter des politiques
à mener pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique.
Parmi les sujets les plus préoccupants
chaque année,
il y a la montée du niveau des océans.
Dans son dernier rapport, le GIEC, Groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental
sur l'évolution du climat, constate
qu'entre 1900 et 2018,
le niveau moyen de la mer
s'est élevé de 20 centimètres.
Et le phénomène accélère.
Alors que la hausse du niveau
s'établissait à 1,4 mm par an en moyenne
durant la période 1900-1990, il grimpe
désormais à 3,6 mm par an.
Au rythme où vont les choses.
Le niveau des océans
pourrait augmenter de 50 cm d'ici 2100
et les scénarios les plus pessimistes
envisagent même une élévation
qui pourrait dépasser un mètre
d'ici la fin du XXIᵉ siècle.
Voici à quoi pourrait ressembler
le trait de côte dans moins d'un siècle,
si le niveau des océans monte d'un mètre.
En rouge, ce sont les zones côtières qui
pourraient être submergées par les eaux.
En 2100.
Les plus touchées par ce phénomène
sont l'embouchure de la Seine,
la côte atlantique et, dans une moindre
mesure, la côte méditerranéenne.
Parmi les grandes villes
les plus menacées, on trouve.
Le Havre, Caen, Bordeaux, Arcachon, Deauville, Bayonne, Toulon et Sète
Certains sites touristiques, comme la baie de Somme, pourraient carrément
être engloutis.
Pour mesurer les dégâts
provoqués par la montée des eaux,
pas la peine de se projeter dans le futur.
La mer a déjà gagné du terrain
dans de nombreuses zones.
Sur le littoral aquitain par exemple,
elle a, par endroits,
avancé de 100 à 150 mètres.
Symbole de ce phénomène, l'immeuble
Le Signal, situé à Soulac-sur-Mer,
en Gironde.
Construit en 1967, il était à l'époque
à 200 mètres du rivage.
Il n'était plus qu'à
une dizaine de mètres de l'eau.
Il y a quelques mois, pour éviter qu'il
ne s'écoule dans l'océan, il a été détruit
en février dernier.
Le constat est le même
sur la côte méditerranéenne,
aux Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer,
dans les Bouches du Rhône.
Les experts estiment
qu'avec la montée des eaux,
la commune pourrait très bientôt
devenir une presqu'île.
Une partie de la Camargue
est d'ailleurs condamnée à disparaître
puisque la majorité de son territoire
est située à moins d'un mètre
au dessus du niveau de la mer.
En France,
près de 1,4 million de personnes
pourraient vivre sous la ligne de marée
haute d'ici à 2050.
Depuis l'Aquitaine au Hauts de France,
En Charente-Maritime,
où se situe l'île de Ré,
les perspectives sont
tout aussi alarmantes, à en croire
un rapport publié par Climate Central,
un organisme américain.
Ce département sera sérieusement impacté d'ici 2050
Et une carte établie par le Bureau de recherches géologiques et minières
montre que l'île perdrait 50% de sa surface
si le niveau des eaux
augmentait d'un mètre.
Ça s'est d'ailleurs
déjà produit pendant quelques jours
en 2010,
après le passage de la tempête Xynthia.
Comment expliquer cette
montée du niveau des océans ?
Depuis 1900,
on l'a dit, le niveau des mers
mesuré par les marégraphes
et plus récemment par les satellites,
est monté de 20 centimètres.
En cause le réchauffement climatique.
Il est dû aux émissions de gaz à effet
de serre liées à l'activité humaine.
Les gaz à effet de serre
sont naturellement présents
en faible quantité dans notre atmosphère.
Leur rôle est déterminant dans le maintien
d'une température terrestre vivable.
Les gaz à effet de serre
retiennent en fait une partie
du rayonnement infrarouge
provoquée par le rayonnement solaire.
Le problème, c'est que l'augmentation de
la concentration de gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère fait grimper
le thermomètre à la surface du globe.
La température s'est élevée
d'un peu plus d'un degré
par rapport à la période préindustrielle.
En France, c'est un peu plus 1,7 degrés.
C'est le constat indiscutable
qu'ont fait les experts du GIEC.
Il y a une corrélation
entre l'augmentation des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
depuis le début de l'ère industrielle
et l'augmentation de la température
à la surface de la planète.
Le premier de ces gaz, c'est
le dioxyde de carbone CO2.
Il provient essentiellement
de la combustion des énergies fossiles,
le charbon, le gaz et le pétrole
qu'on emploie
dans l'industrie, à la maison
ou encore dans les transports.
Deux autres gaz sont impliqués
le protoxyde d'azote
émis par la production d'engrais agricoles
ou encore les gaz fluorés employés
comme réfrigérant dans les climatisations
et enfin le méthane.
Les principales émanations de ce gaz
sont produites par le système digestif
des ruminants, les vaches et les moutons.
L'une des conséquences du réchauffement
climatique.
Ça tombe sous le sens,
c'est la fonte des glaces.
Quand on évoque ce phénomène,
on pense tout de suite à la banquise,
au pôle Nord comme au pôle Sud,
elle fond à vue d'œil.
Les scientifiques estiment par exemple
que l'Arctique
pourrait être privé de sa banquise
en été dès les années 2030. C'est demain.
Dans les faits,
ce sont des milliards de litres
de glaces qui retournent à l'état liquide.
Mais contrairement aux apparences,
ce n'est pas ce qui fait monter
le niveau des océans. J'explique.
À la différence des glaciers continentaux du Groenland et de l'Antarctique,
qui sont composés d'eau douce continentale,
la banquise, elle, est composée
d'eau de mer.
Elle est le résultat de la congélation
de l'océan entre -1 et -2 degrés.
Autrement dit, c'est un énorme glaçon
qui flotte sur un énorme récipient.
La mer comme ce glaçon plongé
dans un verre d'eau
rempli à ras bord qui apparaît à l'écran.
Et que se passe-t-il quand le glaçon fond ?
Rien.
Le niveau reste le même.
Eh bien, le même phénomène
se produit avec la banquise.
L'eau de fonte
occupe exactement le même volume
que la glace occupait
sans modifier le niveau de la mer.
On l'a compris,
ce n'est donc pas la fonte de la banquise
qui fait monter le niveau des océans.
Il faut plutôt regarder du côté
des glaciers terrestres, notamment
les calottes qui recouvrent le Groenland
et bien sûr l'Antarctique.
Reprenons l'exemple du glaçon.
Cette fois,
il est placé à l'extérieur du verre
alors que celui-ci est toujours
plein à ras bord.
J'ai ajouté une petite gouttière
pour canaliser l'eau de fonte.
Vous le voyez
quand le glaçon fond le niveau monte
et cette fois, le verre déborde.
Selon le GIEC, la fonte des glaces
va s'accélérer considérablement
dans les années à venir.
Mais jusqu'à présent,
elle n'était responsable
que de 50% de l'élévation
du niveau des mers.
On va faire une autre expérience.
J'ai rempli cette éprouvette
avec de l'eau froide.
J'ai fait un petit trait rouge
pour marquer le niveau.
Je vais maintenant plonger l'éprouvette
dans une tasse remplie d'eau chaude.
Observez bien le niveau dans l'éprouvette.
Sous l'effet de la chaleur,
l'eau se dilate et le niveau monte.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle la dilatation thermique.
Il se passe exactement la même chose
dans les océans.
A cause du réchauffement climatique,
la température de l'eau augmente
et l'eau se dilate.
Le niveau monte et ce n'est pas terminé.
La fonte de la banquise accentue
ce phénomène de réchauffement.
La surface blanche de la neige
a pour effet de réfléchir
la lumière du soleil et donc de réduire
la production de chaleur.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet albédo.
Sauf que la banquise se réduisant
d'année en année,
cet effet est de moins en moins important.
Et l'océan est de plus en plus exposé
aux rayons lumineux, donc à la chaleur.
On l'a dit, d'après
certains scénarios du GIEC,
la banquise d'été pourrait disparaître
à l'horizon 2030
Au pôle Sud,
d'après une étude parue dans la revue Nature Climate Change,
une partie de la calotte glaciaire
de l'Antarctique occidental
devrait disparaître, quel que soit
le niveau de réchauffement climatique.
Et si la calotte fond,
c'est bien l'eau liée
à la fonte de cette calotte
qui va faire monter le niveau des mers.
Comme on l'a montré plus haut.
D'ailleurs, désormais,
ce phénomène est devenu le principal
responsable de la montée
des eaux, avant la dilatation.
Conséquences ?
Au moins 570 villes risquent
d'avoir de l'eau jusqu'aux genoux.
Façon de parler.
Des mégalopoles comme New York, Shanghaï ou Tokyo,
qui sont situées sur le littoral,
sont donc particulièrement vulnérables
à la montée du niveau des eaux.
Est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il n'y a plus rien à faire ?
Surtout pas.
Même si le phénomène n'est pas réversible, chaque 1/10 de degré
gagné permettra de réduire
les effets du réchauffement climatique.
Les experts estiment qu'il
atteindra 1,5 degré
à l'échelle de la planète
dès le début des années 2030.
Je vous rappelle qu'en 2015,
lors de la COP 21, les pays participants
se sont engagés à contenir
le réchauffement en dessous de 2 degrés.
Pour le moment, on n'y est pas
et c'est le rôle de ces grands messes
comme la COP 28 qui se déroule
en ce moment à Dubaï,
de trouver les moyens de s'en rapprocher
le plus vite possible.
C'est terminé pour aujourd'hui,
je pense que vous l'avez compris,
la situation est très préoccupante
mais pas désespérée.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez
pas à laisser un commentaire
et à vous abonner
si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Excellente semaine à toutes et à tous
et à très bientôt sur la chaîne Épicurieux